for london tennant sarah paying her 700
pound room rent is already a struggle
this is my bedroom
um my bed
i work in here as well i've got my desk
it uses up 60
of her monthly salary and like many in
the rental market she's facing a price
increase
recently we our landlord has um
written to us saying he's increasing the
rent um
50 pounds per person per month um
it doesn't sound a lot but when we're
already trying to scrape together the
rent as it is it is a lot of money to
add on top of that
sarah campaigns for the housing
organization acorn one of many groups
that wants to see more protection for
tenants
what we want to see
is caps and rent controls put in
we can't rely on landlords to regulate
themselves at the end of the day they
are business people and they will take
advantage of opportunities to make as
much profit as they can but a cap on
rent is not currently part of the
government's new renters reform bill
which it says will create a fairer deal
for tenants the bill will offer more
protection banning things like no fault
evictions and giving renters more power
to challenge poor housing conditions and
unjustified rent increases but campaign
groups say it doesn't go far enough
arvind has rented her room in bristol
for five years
the city has seen one of the biggest
leaps in room rental costs up more than
20
from the start of 2019.
i and millions in the same position as
me live with the constant fear you know
we're only one envelope away from being
unable to afford our rent that is just
the whim of a landlord there's nothing
to stop them from deciding they want
more money and increasing the rent at
any moment but organizations
representing landlords say increasing
rents is not a case of profiteering so i
wish it were as simple as landlords
getting greedy and deciding they want to
make more profit actually we're seeing
the opposite we're seeing our members
yields you know what their return on
investment go down because it's that
much more expensive to buy property it's
that much more expensive to run a
business so actually where we're seeing
the increase is it's to cover things
like increased tax utility bills cost of
management it's not because they're
protecting a margin there are 4.4
million private renters in the uk
with energy bills set to rise again this
autumn they are looking for even more
protection to ensure the homes they have
stay affordable
tom whitehead sky news in bristol